so on Monday I talked about conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones and how he really
seems to be sort of just not doing well
psychologically doesn't look good for
whatever standards you want to apply to
Alex Jones and it's sort of like refresh
your memory I met Alex Jones in person
years ago at a talk radio conference and
my reaction to meeting him was that his
on-air persona is a character he seemed
to sort of recognize the wacky nature of
that character and to turn it off when
he's just having kind of normal
conversations with people so for years I
thought Alex Jones was a character then
I interviewed his ex-wife or is then
soon-to-be ex-wife I don't know if
they're estranged or separated or
divorced or what's going on anyway she
said it's not a character and it's
increasingly clear to me that it's
probably not a character that Alex Jones
plays most recently he was kicked off a
bunch of platforms for violating terms
and conditions this includes YouTube and
Facebook I believe Spotify iTunes kicked
them off all sorts of places
kicking Alex Jones off deciding that the
content violates their terms and
conditions okay so Monday or late last
week I did a story about how Jones truly
seems to have had some kind of a
psychological incident some kind of a
deterioration in his mental state I
don't know exactly what you want to call
it but he's put on a serious amount of
weight his demeanor has become even
stranger he's proposing even more
bizarre conspiracy theories about the
eating of human pituitary glands as
hallucinogenic sort of like magic
mushrooms something seems to be very
very wrong and I discussed this and a
few days after that podcaster and
comedian Joe Rogan mentioned that I had
talked about that on my program on his
program and he pointed out that yes
something seems to be really wrong with
Alex Jones but Joe clarified that he
doesn't hate Alex Jones if he ran into
him in person he would give him a hug
but that something does seem to be wrong
with Alex Jones which is a perfectly
reasonable commentary Alex Jones
now declared war on Joe Rogan and as
usual with Alex Jones it's hard to tell
what the line is between attention
trolling and and reality it's hard to
tell what the line is between Alex Jones
the character and Alex Jones the actual
person but he's promoting the fact that
he's doing this on his conspiracy
website Infowars where he has a headline
Alex Jones declares war against Joe
Rogan he did a very long video about
this I'm just gonna play like one
section for you but Jones goes on to say
that Joe Rogan isn't his friend that
he's not ever talking to him again that
he's going to destroy him all sorts of
other stuff take a look the video Joe
Rogan put out I couldn't even watch all
of it but we're gonna play it coming up
together the like he talks to people
like their children like all his prey
like he talks to me like I'm one of his
prey and and and like oh if I saw you
here you're still my friend just stop
what you're doing Alex and all the rest
of this crap this is gold-plated BS when
we play it Joe Rogan literally does all
these sorrows talking points from Soros
organizations he cites Soros
organizations and then says I'm a liar
no I'm not a liar so you can run run run
you can run run run but you can't get
away for your date with destiny Joe Joe
Joe Rogan it metaphysically is a
Christmas hog and I'm gonna politically
haul him up by his back legs and slit
his throat his blood will fill buckets
politically not so this goes on get
ready Joe for 30 minutes I'm not gonna
subject you to the entire thing but
here's just like one other moment from
it all of it every bit of it everything
because you're there darling I figured
it out you're there baby cake you were
there model for the future
you're who they think I'll be on the
internet when no one else is is some
guru to everyone and and it's just not
gonna happen
I'm built for war
Joe yeah I don't act like a tough girl
today I'm just I do the war you
understand so so the threats don't
matter to me the the so clearly Alex
Jones isn't well and I mean I get it his
business has sort of imploded under him
or a big part of it has this isn't about
feeling bad for Alex Jones per se he
spread so much misinformation in
conspiracy nonsense that really has
damaged people it's also not about
agreeing with everything Joe Rogan says
there does I mean I know a lot of my
audience doesn't agree with Joe and
that's fine I don't agree with
everything that Joe Rogan says and does
and there's lots of topics we could talk
about with Joe Rogan but Joe Rogan
responded in a completely sort of
reasonable calm sober adult manner and
this is very very marginal behavior and
it's kind of a new pattern for Alex
Jones because he's making specific
threats to individuals and that's not
usually his pattern from what I've seen
and observed and now I'm kind of
remembering I think that at some point
Joe Rogan had said he also believes Alex
Jones is playing a character which I
believed for a while I've been disabused
of that notion I don't think that Alex
Jones is playing a character at least
not at this point
I wonder whether Joe Rogan has also
changed his mind about it after seeing
what it is that's going on here if
you're Joe Rogan do you take these as
serious threats like what what is it
that Alex Jones is capable of or do you
merely write them off as kind of empty
threats to get attention particularly
because it's been so hard for the
Infowars business to continue and
sustain itself after Alex Jones lost all
of those platforms I don't know the
answer but it's abundantly clear that
something here is wrong with Alex Jones
but in a way that goes beyond just being
comfortable as a sort of propagandist of
conspiracy theories this now is getting
into personal threats this now is
getting into something that we we even
hadn't seen before very very strange and
I'd be curious to see what you think
about it